Musik Telekom, bumbum bumbum, Telekom, Internet, bumbum bumbum, Telekom, Internet, Router, Router, Router, Router, Router ist exkludiert, oh nein, der das Wohnzimmer brennt. Was machen wir jetzt? Ich bam, bam, bam auch mal kurz sagen, ich bin stolz, dass ich hier ein Teil des lustigen Formats sein kann, was so viele Menschen so oft ein Lachen ins Gesicht zaubert, hoffe ich, und wollte mich jetzt erstellend ganz kurz bedanken bei dir, Florinchen Will. Danke, ja, ich bin auch ein Teil dieses Konglomerats der guten Laune, ach ja, weiß ich nicht, Co-Moderator, glaube ich, steht auf der Pufopedia, Co-Moderator in der Sidekick, ja, Sidekick in der Florian Wildshow. Naja, das hat jemand geschrieben, der uns gerade entdeckt hat, durch die nette Erwähnung bei Fest und Flauschig, hat jemand geschrieben, besonders lustig findet er den latenten Rassismus von dem Dicken. Wo ich mich frage, da wir im Podcast sind, woher erdenkt, einer von uns wäre dick, und es ist auch noch der mit dem latenten Rassismus. Frage, wen meint er? Das sind übrigens die Hörer der fünften Ordnung, die fest und flauschig, die jetzt dazugekommen sind, die fest und flauschig. Der absolute Abschaum, die ekelhaften Mainstream-Widerlichen, die sich an jeden neuen Trend dranklammern, denn mit so richtig ekelhaften Fettfingern klammern die sich an jeden vorbeifahrenden Zug fest und ich würde sie am liebsten so abwischen, so wegstauben mit so einem grossen Besen. Ja, oder einfach in die Wanne stecken und mit so einem Handtuch drüber schruppen, bis sie sauber sind. Hast du schon mal jemand anderem die Haare getrocknet? Hast du die Haare gerubbelt? Nein. Nein. Ich glaube... Und ich finde, das ist so ein Ding, was man ab 30 machen darf. Weil dann ist es, glaube ich, gesellschaftlich erlaubt, wenn du Kindern zum Beispiel die Haare rubbelst, weil das deine Kinder sind oder so. Aber ich glaube, bis dahin hast du keinen Grund, andere Menschen die Haare sauber zu machen. Ich glaube, ich würde das gerne mal machen. Ich glaube, ich finde, das hat so ein... Findest du auch, dass Haare immer gleich riechen? Also im gewaschenen Zustand riechen Haare von Menschen oft gleich. Du meinst, die Haare von allen Menschen riechen dann gleich? Ja, du hast so einen Kopfhautgeruch, der eigentlich ganz angenehm ist, anders als das Wort vielleicht warten lässt. Ja, man sagt ja zum Beispiel auch, dass Babys die Köpfe ganz total gut riechen. Ja, deswegen sieht man immer Mütter, die immer mit der Nase an den Kindern reiben. Gibt's mir ja, Jerry! Ja, ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen, irgendwie so. Auch dass man immer so das Bedürfnis hat, diesen Kopf so zu drücken, so. Ja, auch weil der so einfach einzudrücken ist, wie Knete. Ja, was? Gestern gab es Knete netto im Angebot. Echt? Ich habe echt überlegt, mir Knete zu kaufen. Welche Farbe? Rot, gelb, grün und blau. Das Problem an Knete ist, dass du am Ende eigentlich immer braune Knete hast, weil sich alles immer vermischt. Ja, braun mit so Staubakzenten drin, so Staubakzenten. Legostein noch drin, so benutzen Kondom irgendwo drin. Cornflakes-Dinge da drin, Fruit Loop. Sagt man allen Fruit Loop? Ja, Fruit Loop. Aber warum Loop? Ja, Kreis halt, Loop. Ja, sehr naheliegend, ne? Das bin ich ja. Ich mag ja, was ich ja immer sage, ich mag am liebsten Tresor. Das sind so eine Cornflakes-Art, die nicht so viele... Ne, Tresor. Tresor wird, glaube ich, anders geschrieben. Tresor ist mega geil. Also das sind diese kleinen, diese Weizen-Pockets. Ist auch nicht Weizen, das ist irgendwas. Fett-Pockets. Synthetisch. Da drin sind dannat-Creme. Ich bin von Nuss-Nougat-Creme, außer von Nutella, echt kein großer Freund, weil irgendwie, finde ich, das trifft es immer nicht so ganz, aber das trifft es sehr gut. Also das ist auch etwas, was man mit Milch sehr gut essen kann. Du bist aber auch ein Original-Cornflex-Käufer, ne? Also sowas dann die Lidl-Knusperrone oder sowas kommt bei dir überhaupt nicht in Einkaufswagen. Ich wünschte immer, ich könnte das, aber oft bin ich ein Original, Fan des Originals. Auch wenn ich oft das Original nicht kenne, würde ich das wahrscheinlich lieber mögen. Du könntest mir das immer zeigen und ich würde immer am liebsten auch die billige Version gut finden, weil die ist ja dann halt billiger und dann würde ich mehr Geld haben am Ende des Monats und muss nicht wieder alles auf meiner Wohnung bei Ebay versteigern. Ich verkaufe übrigens gerade ein Klavier, weil ich durch die vielen Cornflakes mittlerweile echt in die Perule gekommen bin. Also so viel Geld klappt am Ende des Monats nicht über. Du musst an Prioritäten setzen natürlich. Ja, ich verkaufe viele Dinger jetzt aus meiner Wohnung. Also wenn ihr Interesse habt an zum Beispiel einem Klavier, einem sehr guten Kampffischisch, sehr guten Gitarrenständer, aber hier muss ich sagen, das ist was für Bastler, weil da ist ein bisschen was abgebrochen. Das ist auch gut, dass sich das durchgesetzt hat, dass wenn man was kaputtes verkauft, schreibt für Bastler. Nein, das ist für Idioten. Oder einfach, man kann auch sagen, für Idioten. Für Leute, die kaputte Sachen mö Sachen mögen. Ja, bestimmt für alles so Liebhabermärkte. Apropos Liebhaber, neue Geschichten aus dem Supermarktuniversum von Stefan Titz. Wir waren gestern beim Netto und haben, glaube ich, den grössten Toffifee-Liebhaber der Welt gesichtet. Noch nie hat ein Mensch so nach Toffifee geschrien. Aber die Geschichte ist so vielseitig, wir werfen so viele Fragen auf. Ja, aber auch viele Antworten. Also ich habe viele Antworten in die Geschichte bekommen. Also ich gar nicht. Also erst mal finde ich, was einen richtig guten Kunden ausmacht, ist, dass man ihn mit Personal verwechseln kann. Ja. Weil wir standen an der Kasse und neben uns da war so eine grosse Kiste Toffee-Fee aufgebaut, so wie Stapelweise. Und dann kam jemand an und hat wirklich immer so mit der grösstmöglichen Länge seiner Hand immer so packenweise Toffee-Ges. In die Toffee-Fee war so ein grosser Basin aus Toffee-Fee, hat er immer reingegriffen und hat sich was rausgenommen. Aber wie man das bei, wenn man zum Beispiel Kirschen oder so Nüsse kauft, wiegt er das immer mit der Hand so. Er hat immer so drei, vier Packungen Toffee-Fee genommen, hat die dann in der Hand gewogen, so nachdenklich nach oben rechts geschaut, hat dann so die auf und ab bewegt und hat sie dann in seinen Karton gepackt. Ja, aber der hat geguckt, in welcher die beste Überraschung ist, so ein bisschen so. Welcher ist, was zusammenbaut. Er hat Toffife auch nicht ganz verstanden, glaube ich. Nicht ganz. Ich dachte tatsächlich, er ist sein Mitarbeiter, der könnte gerade miträumen oder sowas. Ja, aber dann stellte sich heraus, hat eine große Kiste genommen, hat sich an die Kasse hinter uns angestellt und hat einfach mal 20, wie viel waren es? Lass es 35 gewesen sein, 35 Toffeefehlpackungen, aber das ist auch geil, das zog sich an aufwürdigenden, sehr guten Kunden aus, einen weirden, aber sehr guten Kunden, dass er diese Verpackungen nimmt, die quasi, wo die ganzen Toffeefehlverpackungen drin sind dann. Das heißt, er hat nicht nur die Verpackungen von Toffee-Vier genommen, sondern die, die die Supermärkte bekommen, wo mehrere Packungen Toffee-Vier drin sind, diese Paletten, die hat er genommen. Und das finde ich immer geil, wenn man diese Paletten nimmt, wo dann die einzelnen Verpackungen drin sind, die man in den Supermarkt dann so kaufen kann. Wenn man das nimmt, hat man gewonnen. Dann ist man für mich ein Kunde des Monats, mindestens in meiner Arbeit des Jahres. Allerdings, kurz bevor er hätte zahlen müssen, hat er dann den gesamten Karton Toffifee nochmal von dem Laufband runtergenommen, hat sie auf die Eistruhe gestellt und hat gesagt, ich muss nochmal kurz zu meinem Auto. Er war auch noch gar nicht dran, er hätte nichts sagen müssen theoretisch, hat es aber weggestellt auf diese Eistruhe. Und er hat dann den Supermarkt verlassen. Und der hat es auch so angekündigt, so, ich muss noch mal kurz zu meinem Auto, so,
einfach so als der schlechtmöglichste Mörder, so, ich hab kein Messer in der Hand gerade. Ich muss noch mal kurz das Messer, äh, das Pop-Mondee. Den Blumenstrauß weg, und er ist dann gegangen, und wir wissen nicht, wie es sich weiterhin gesponnen hat, vielleicht ist er einfach weggefahren vom Parkplatz.
Aber dann kam er wieder rein und hat, glaube ich, nur ein bisschen mehr Geld geholt, weil er dann noch mehr ...
Noch mehr Toffee-Fressen wollte. fahren, vvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvvv Toffife hat aber keine Witze verstanden, er hat dann nämlich gesagt, ich muss noch mehr Geld holen und dann haben wir gesagt, so im Spaß, oh, noch nicht genug Toffife oder so gekauft und er hat einfach nicht darauf reagiert, er wurde glaube ich so ein bisschen rot sogar, also ihm war das unangenehm, die Menge an Toffife. Was war das für eine Party, was hat er da gefeiert? Ich weiss es nicht genau, ehrlich gesagt. Ich stelle mir vor, dass er irgendwie so ein Erklärvideo hat. Er will Brexit erklären und die englische Wirtschaft erklären und macht dann so ein Video und dann so, okay, wir haben tausend Toffifees, jeder steht für hundert Bürger und erzählt das dann so und braucht deswegen wahnsinnig viele Toffifees in der Richtung. Aber ich finde es auch gut, dass er sich auf dem Laufband entschieden hat, so ich habe 35 Kartons, 35 Parkmann, nee, das reicht nicht, ich brauche mehr, ich brauche noch mehr, ich renne noch mal kurz zu meinem Auto, hole mehr Geld, um einfach noch mehr zu holen. Aber diese Entscheidung, erst mal 35 und dann, ich brauche noch mehr. Ich will die Wohnung von ihm sehen einfach. Ich will wirklich wissen, wie wohnt der. Wohnt der, weiss ich nicht, speist der auf einem Thron aus Toffifee oder so? Was genau ist das, was er da ... Ich glaube, er wohnt in so einem großen Toffifee drin, wie so ein UFO einfach, wo in der Mitte so eine riesige Haselnuss hängt in seiner Wohnung. Die Lampe ist so eine große Diskokug ist so eine große, so eine Dutzig-Diskokugel, so eine grosse Haselnuss, die sich einfach so langsam im Licht dreht. Ja, bist du ein Lutscher oder ein Beisser, was Toffi-Fies angeht? Äh, Lutscher. Manchmal aber habe ich, es sieht einfach aus, ja, Langeweile, dann manchmal beisse ich einfach rein, um die Packung möglichst schnell zu vermischen. Um noch möglichst viel Langeweile zu haben. Ja, weil ich tunks noch in Nutella. Aber ich bin noch mal zurück zu dem Typen. Ja. Was macht der da abends? Hat der eine Toffee-Fee-Verheirge? Eine Toffee-Fete? Eine Toffee-Fete, es gibt eine Tupper-Party, so etwas gibt es ja auch. Da ist ja so eine Toffee-Fee-Dealer, der abends dann dann nochmal solche Leute einlädt und die einfach diese Plastikwannen haben, wo einfach nur Toffifee drin sind.
Weil es einfach, das ist ein Fetisch, so ein Toffifee, Toffifeetisch.
Toffifeetisch.
Hm, Toffifee, die Toffifee.
Ja.
Toffife, Toffifeengshui die Toffee-Fee, Toffee-Feng-Shui, Toffee-Phobie, Toffee. Wenn Sie mehr Ideen haben für Toffee-Fee-Wortspiele, schick Sie eine Postkarte an 088-488-688-888-888-8-Jail. Ich habe aber neulich auch was Seltsames gesehen, und zwar war ich in einer U-Bahn und dann kam jemand, es war sehr voll, muss man dazu sagen, weil die auch irgendwie, da war vorher so ein Stellwerkschaden oder so, und dann kamen erst lange keine U-Bahn, und dann werden die ja immer sehr voll, weil halt immer mehr Leute auf diese gleiche U-Bahn warten. Und dann kam jemand mit so einem, also ich würde mal sagen, ich bin zwei Meter gross ungefähr, der war ungefähr zwei Meter fünfzig gross, ein Sack, ein durchsichtiger Sack, gefüllt mit diesem weissen Füllmaterial, was man manchmal findet, wenn man irgendwie einen Fernseher kauft oder so, diese kleinen Noppen, diese weicheren Styropor-Krümel, die ein bisschen grösser sind. Hat einfach so einen Riesensack aus Füllmaterial, und die U-Bahn war wahnsinnig voll. Heißt, es waren halt ... Also man konnte nicht ... Man musste sich hier immer festhalten, musste ich nicht, weil ich an diesem Sack gelehnt war einfach. Überall waren Menschen und dieser grosse Sack. Und es hat einfach zu so einem Lacher geführt. Und die ganze U-Bahn hat plötzlich angefangen zu lachen einfach, weil es sehr lustig war, dass sie so einen gross Sack zu haben einfach, und dann mussten immer Leute raus, dann musste er den immer nehmen, musste dann rausgehen und es hat immer dieses Knarren und Geräusch gegeben. Ich finde es so lustig, dass du daneben stehst und dann, das wird immer enger, das Gedränge wird immer grösser und du verschwindest so komplett in diesem Ding einfach und bist da so drin, wie man in so einem fetten Menschen verschwindet, wenn er irgendwie zu nahe kommt und einfach weg ist. dann kam ein älterer Herr mit so einem Rollator rein, der sich dann, weil die Bahn so schnell anfuhr, in diesen Sack gefallen ist. Weich fiel natürlich, was gut war. So eine halbe Stuntshow einfach, so macht so ein Salto in diesen Sack rein. Dann kam der Besitzer, der sich davor bei Hingesitzer war, zu welchen Sitzplatz bekommen hat, hat diesen Sack alleine gelassen, der ist dann aufgestanden und ist zu dem Meinen hingegangen. Und dann habe ich erst nicht gehört, was er gesagt hat. Ich dachte mir, können Sie bitte aufhören, so aggressiv in meinen Sack zu fassen, weil das gehört sich ja auch nicht. Aber er hat wohl nur gesagt, soll ich den vielleicht wegstellen, damit sie besser stehen können. Und dann musste er die nächste Station raus, der ältere Herr, und dann musste er das Wende in den Sack nehmen und raus. Das war echt, das war total Chaos ausgeboren, was ich echt lustig fand. Das ist das Schlimmste, was man transportieren kann. Vor allem ist es ja so nutzlos, wenn man irgendwie ein Cello transportiert oder so, dann haben die Leute ja Verständnis, dass man sagt, ja okay, das ist wichtig, das ist teuer, der muss halt irgendwo hin, um anderen Leuten Freude zu bereiten. Aber diese Styropor-Dinger ist einfach so nutzlos, die sind einfach Platzhalter, Platzfüller, dass wenn du in einem Karton noch mehr Platz haben willst, die sind eigentlich toter Raum, einfach negativer Raum sind diese Dinger. Was man in einer überfüllten U-Bahn am wenigsten will, in einem toten Raum. Überhaupt nicht einfach, du willst nicht, dass der leere Raum gefüllt wird, einfach mit diesen Styropor-Dingern. Das ist wie so einen grossen Ballon, den man so, einen Heissluftballon, den man in der U-Bahn aufbläst. Ja, aber stell dir mal vor, das Ding wäre aufgerissen und diese gesamten Styropor-Dinger wären rausgefallen, er müsste durch allen Füssen durchkrammeln, sorry, sorry. Aber das B war immer, dass sich keiner bewegen konnte, die U-Bahn verlassen konnte, ehe er nicht den Sack genommen hat, mit dieser demütigen Bewegung, weil der war halt sehr breit, der musste den immer so umarmen. Es gab keine Chance, den cool zu transportieren, da ist immer ein Mann, kommt einfach so ein kleines Typ, ist aufgestanden, der sass auch, er stand nicht bei seinem Sack, er ist einfach aufgestanden, hat jetzt den Sack sehr innig umarmt, hat ihm einen Riesenen Hack gegeben und ist dann hochgenommen und ist rausgegangen. Das war echt, das hat immer so ganz seltsam in so befremdlichen Situationen geführt. Das ist so gut, wenn er auf dem Sack noch so einen grossen Smiley drauf gemalt hätte und so ein Gesicht oder so. Er hat immer so, komm her, wir gehen doch mal, wir gehen jetzt. Ah, sehr schön. Aber das war wirklich, wo ich auch mal sagen musste, das ist wirklich toll an Köln. Leute sind nett, Leute sind auch tolerant gegenüber so grossen Füllmaterialien in der U-Bahn. Und die haben gelacht und die fanden das toll und die fanden das lustig, dass so ein Riesending, wo alle so halb drin hängen. Das fanden die ganz toll. Aber auch hier die Frage, was hat er danach damit gemacht? Warum braucht man so eine Menge an Füllmaterial? Was will er füllen? Was ist sein Leben so leer, dass es mit Füllmaterial füllen kann? Da wird ein grosses Loch in sich selbst. Kann sein. Aber ich hatte mal einen grossen Sitzsack und der war auch gefüllt mit so Styroporküppelchen. Das kann sein. So und dann, der ist auch irgendwann aufgerissen und es war auch riesen, riesen Kleideradatsch, Schlamassel. Riesenschein. Riesen, riesen Kram und er kann ja sein, dass er sich sowas selber baut, dass er sagt so, Hä, 30 Euro für so einen Sitzsack? Nee, kaufe mir für 5 Euro so Styropor-Dinger und tu dir irgendwie eine Altitüte, da habe ich genauso gut einen Sitzsack. Ich hatte mal einen Hängestuhl in meiner Kindheit, also das ist so wie eine Hängematte, nur halt kleiner, also halt, dass man alleine drin sitzt. Hast du, glaube ich, mal erzählt, der sich mal gedreht hat. Ja genau. Folge drei. Ihr könnt die besten Geschichten auch einfach nochmal in der Puffopedia nachlesen, wir haben Zuhörer mit sehr gutem Gedächtnis. Aber ist die Puffopedia wieder Nein. Die ist nämlich jetzt down, komplett, oder? Die ist komplett down, die ist komplett überflutet von Spam und von expansivem Spam und das ist eine Katastrophe und ich will nicht da bei diesem Support anrufen, weil weil wir müssen erst bei dem Support anrufen, dass sie die Seite wieder freigeben und der wird dann so Fragen stellen wie … Das ist der Support wie, was ist mit der, was ist mit der Tabelle da, WP unter Strich sechs. Und der wird dann einfach so unangenehme Fragen stellen, die meine Inkompetenz einfach zu unangenehm an Tage treten lassen. Aber das ist so Klischee, dass man bei der IT anruft und die irgendein Pornokram feststellen. Das ist so Klischee, dann haben wir da angerufen und dann hat er die Tabelle WP-Sex gefunden, was der schlechteste Name ist. Ja, vor allem, wenn es halt wenigstens Porno gewesen wäre, wenn es halt irgendwie WP-Gangbang oder so WP-Sad-Midget-Porn. Aber WP-Sex, das sind auch noch so Sex. Das sind so wie ein schlechtes Drehbuch, so schlechte Drehbuchautoren, die einen Gag schreiben. Ja, genau. Leute, dann rufen die bei der RT-Abteilung an, ich habe die mega Idee für ein Skript, Jeff. Dann rufen die bei der RT-Abteilung an und dann kommt da unterstrich WP unterstrich Sex. Ja. Nee, und da habe ich keinen Bock anzurufen, weil der einfach Fragen stellen wird, die mich einfach in meine Inkompetenz ermüden lassen werden. Und dann einfach sagt sich, ja, was haben sie denn da angestellt und einen Hörer. Aber das ist toll, weil wenn du telefonierst, du kannst immer so tun, als würdest du gerade durch den Tunnel fahren.
Was, hallo, was haben sie gerade gesagt, ich, oh, ich sage es nicht mehr.
Ja, bei Filmen machen das Leute manchmal, dass sie durch die Krawatte reden, was bringt das denn?
Man hat auch so selten eine Krawatte.
Ja, ja, also, coole Filmprotagonisten haben häufig Krawatten, Ja, ja. Oder in den Tasser, habe ich auch schon mal aufgehört.
Coole Filmprotagonisten haben häufig Krawatten, die so über den Kopf, den Hörer dann die Krawatte legen. Ich weiß nicht, was das bringen soll. Oder soll das irgendwie so Abdrücke verhindern oder irgendwie sowas, dass man dann die Atem-DNA an dem, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich weiss auch nicht, wenn man Bösewichte hört, die Drohungen mitteilen in Filmen, dann hört man die ja auch oft so tief.
Hallo, bringen Sie das Geld, bringen Sie die, ich gönne Ihnen Lisa Meier, für eine Million Euro, bekommen Sie das Mädchen wieder.
Aber ich stelle mir immer vor, weil ich habe oft darüber nachgedacht, warum haben die jetzt diese tiefe Stimme.
Ich habe mir immer vorgestellt, wie die mit so einem Kindermegafon so ein Spielzeug dann vor dem Telefon sitzen und dann so reinsprechen, was immer die ein bisschen entgruselt hat. Also es sollte ja immer so bedrohlich sein, wenn man dann tut doch eine Million Euro Lösegeld, dann bekommen sie sie am Lidl-Parkplatz. Aber dann ist es halt so ein Typ, der in so einem Megafon spricht. Vor allem spätestens dann weisst du, dass du ein Bösewicht bist. Man fragt sich ja immer so, wissen böse Leute, dass sie böse sind?
Wussten die Nazis damals, dass sie die Bösewichte der Geschichte sind? Die haben schwarze Uniform, wo Tod draufsteht. Oder dachten sie, die wären die Guten. Aber auch da, ich glaube, spätestens wenn du dir so ein Gerät kaufst, dass deine Stimme tiefer und bedrohlicher wirkt, da denkst du dir, ja, wahrscheinlich bin ich der Bösewicht dieser Geschichte. Der Kaufprozess ist ja relativ normal. Also da musst du auch den auf Netto Kassenband legen und so. Und das ist doch auch, du denkst doch nicht, böse Leute kaufen das jetzt nicht für 3,99 Euro bei Netto und müssen die Frage, wollen sie einen Kassenbon dazu beantworten, ja oder nein. Das ist doch auch nichts, was die Bösewichte machen. Ich bin auf der Suche nach so einem Stimmverzerrer, dass meine Stimme so ein bisschen tiefer klingt, einfach ein bisschen männlicher.
Haben Sie das schon mal mit einer Krawatte ausprobiert?
Ich trage leider keine Krawatten, ich bin Schreiner.
Da ist das immer schlecht, weil das kommt dann immer in die Schnittmaschine rein.
Aber mal kurz zur Frage, warum wollen Sie denn Ihre Stimme tief machen, weil das machen ja eigentlich normalerweise nur böse Menschen.
Nein!
Das ist jetzt kein böser Mensch.
Nein, ich bin kein, nein, ich habe da nur so ein, ich habe da so ein grosses Säurebecken in meinem Wohnzimmer aufgebaut und da gibt es so einen Typen, den kenne ich schon seit meiner Kindheit irgendwie und da hatten wir ein bisschen Probleme und jetzt habe ich halt irgendwie seine Freundin entführt und über dieses Säurebecken gehängt und der kommt am Wochenende vorbei, glaube ich, um die Freundin zu retten und ich dachte mir, es wäre eigentlich ganz geil, wenn man mal so ein bisschen irgendwie so ein bisschen von der Stimme was machen könnte. Ähm, mich hätte eine Sache stutzig gemacht, die Sie gesagt haben. Ja. Sie kennen die Person schon sehr lange. Ja. Das ist schön, das freut mich. Ja, es ist... Ich meine, so lange Kontakte hat man mittlerweile ja gar nicht mehr so oft. Ja, ja. Wir wollen im schnellen Leben. Ja, kein Problem, ich habe da was auf Lager. Ist allerdings für Kinder, so ein kleines Megafon. Es hat diese drei Tasten, die müssen dann auf die eine drücken, da wird ihre Stimme tiefer.
Auf die Kuh oder die? Nee, sie müssen auf den Esel drücken, da wird ihre Stimme tiefer. Bei der Kuh kommt ein Muu-Geräusch. Ich mach mal kurz vor. Muuu! Ja, das ist ja auch nicht schlecht, sowas in der Hinterhand zu haben. Aber sie dürfen auf gar keinen Fall auf das Schaf klicken, weil dann kommt ein ganz seltsamer Sirenton. Ja, aber wenn Sie unten den Griff aufmachen, da ist Knete drin.
Ach was, welche Farbe denn? Für Ihre Tochter blau, grün und braun schon vorher. Ach braun schon, das ist ja gut. Das ist schon praktisch eigentlich. Ach sind da auch schon Fussel und Legosteine drin? Ja, aber dafür müssen Sie auf den Esel zweimal drücken. Ach, das ist ja nett. Gibt es die auch in anderen Farben als Pink oder ist das die einzige Farbe? Wir haben noch dieses Baby Butter Blau hier und dieses Pink. Baby Butter?
Baby Butter Blau hier und dann dieses Pink. Baby Butter? Baby Butter Blau, das heisst so. Baby Butter oder was? Ja, Baby Butter Blau, das ist die Farbe. Ich weiss auch nicht, der Hersteller hat das so genannt. Wegen Butterfly oder wegen Butter jetzt? Ich bin mir nicht genau sicher, warum der Hersteller das so genannt hat, da bin ich jetzt überfragt, aber das heisst so. Ja, dann nehme ich von dem Pink fünf. Sind da schon Batterien drin oder muss ich die separaten? Fünf Stück. Batterien sind schon drin, ja. Ja, aber ich kann ja dann auch die hintereinander halten. Also wenn ich dann mit der Eselstimme noch mal die Eselstimme und dann noch mal die Kuhstimme mache, dann multipliziert sich das ja. Und dann wird das ja noch tiefer und noch ein bisschen böse, oder? Da muss ich, ja, kann sein. Der Doppel-Esel, dachte ich jetzt. Ja, kann sein, kann auch sein, dass dann Giraffenstimme oder so rauskommt. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab's nicht so mit Gags, ich bin nur ein netter Verkäufer. Das ist okay. Nein, ich probiere einfach mal ein bisschen rum und dann würde ich mich nochmal melden, falls ich noch mehr brauche. Und Sie sind ja hier, oder sind Sie da? Wir haben eine ganz seltsame Aktion im Moment, wir müssen so ein paar Restposten loswerden. Also wenn Sie das Fleischer-Messer, die Steinschleuder, das Säurebecken
und das Megafon kaufen,
dann gibt es einen Mengenrabatt
von insgesamt 10%.
Legen wir den Läserstrahl noch drauf und dann bin ich dabei.
Oh, dann gibt es sogar 15%.
Dann sag ich mal
Arrivederci.
Ciao mit Maui.
Und vergessen Sie nicht, Netto weiter zu empfehlen.
Immer böse bleiben.
Gut bleiben natürlich, alles klar. Ciao. Tschüss. Wie geht es einem Fisch eigentlich? Was treibt der so? Von dem hört man recht wenig irgendwie. Das war ein Fan-Lieb. Er geht mir auf die Nerven. Wir haben gerade so ein bisschen Stress. Ja, was ist los? Also, das Algenproblem bin ich losgeworden. Endlich. Aber jetzt bin ich durch Pflanzen losgeworden, die ich eingesetzt habe. Jetzt sind die Pflanzen aber alle aus dem Boden herausgekommen und schwimmen jetzt an der Oberfläche. Das heisst, den Fisch und mich trennen jetzt so eine drei Zentimeter dicke Schicht aus Pflanzen. Okay. Und weisst du, da ist die Distanz, auch die emotionale Distanz mittlerweile so gross, dass ich auch ... Das ist auch so schwierig, den zu füttern jetzt, weil dann muss er sich da so durchschwenken und ... Ach, das stinkt. So ein Aquarium stinkt. Da muss er ja auch so Mückenlarven, kriegt er ja immer noch so Bullshit. Ach nee. Da kommt jetzt der neue Finding Dory-Film raus, da habe ich so ein Wahnplakat gelesen. Bitte, bitte schaut euch diesen Film an. Werbung, glaube ich, war es so was. Ne, da stand bitte schaut euch zwar den Film an, aber kauft euch nicht diese Fische, weil diese blauen Fische, diese Dory-Fische, wie auch Sönnet Nemo, die kann man nämlich nicht in Gefangenschaft züchten, sondern die muss man halt fangen aus der Wildnis. Also da geht dann jemand los mit einer riesigen Harpune oder irgendwie mit so einem Kescher und fängt dann diese blauen Dory-Fische, damit die Kinder das dann irgendwie zwei Monate lang cool finden können. Deswegen, Leute, auch noch mal an euch, schaut euch den Film an, habt Spaß, aber kauft euch keine Dory-Fische. Sondern fangt sie euch selber. Fangt sie euch selbst, genau. Gab es ja tatsächlich bei Find It Nemo, nachdem der Film Find It Nemo gelaufen ist. Wollten alle Clownsfische haben? Ja, nee, erstens wollten alle Clownsfische haben und alle Kinder, die schon Fische hatten, hatten so viel Mitleid mit ihren Fischen, dass sie die alle im Klo runtergespült haben, weil die dadurch frei werden konnten. Und die haben dann alle umgebracht. Ah, okay, ja klar. Die Kinder so, oh nein, wir wollen die befreien, die sollen ins Meer und so und die haben alle ins Klo geworfen und alle umgebracht. Das ist so, weisst du, die sind ... Hier aber auch noch die Frage, ist es besser in Gefangenschaft zu leben oder zu sterben? Das ist auch so ... Es ist, glaube ich, besser in Gefangenschaft zu leben. Ja, glaube ich auch. Aber ich finde es so lustig, dass so ein ultrasüsser, mit so einer lebensbejahrenden Botschaft Film rauskommt und dann auch einfach der Fische-Massenmord einfach, wo in der ganzen Welt einfach Kinder ihre Tiere getötet haben, einfach alle weg und alle mussten neue Fische kaufen und das waren diese Clownfische. Dadurch sind die jetzt mittlerweile vom Aussterben tot. Ja, aber die Clownfische, die sind ja auch sehr salzwasserfische und auch sehr anspruchsvoll, die brauchen so Riesen-Aquarien, obwohl die so sehr klein sind. Die brauchen auch so eine Riff-Aquarie, wo du selber so Korallen drin haben musst und sowas. Die haben einfach keine Chance zu überleben und ich glaube, sehr viele Kinder werden einfach Clownfische gekauft haben und die sind einfach gestorben, brutal gestorben. Ich finde es einfach so gut, wenn bei Disney irgendwie nach Finding Dory Teil 3, die in so einem Krisenmeeting sitzen, okay, durch unsere Filme sind drei Fischarten einfach ausgestorben. Was machen wir? Machen wir einen Film über ein Haus, was durch sehr viele Luftballons im Himmel steigt? Oh nein! Nein! Ach nein! Das grosse Haus vom Himmel fallen, 2003, er hat alles... Nee, lass uns was machen über eine Ratte in einem Restaurant und Gesundheitsamt und ach nein, Leute! Wir haben aber auch gerade echt Scheisse am Schub, wir wissen nicht genau, was wir machen sollen. Disney schliesst einfach, weil sie die gesamte Welt ruiniert haben. Einfach drei Tierarten ausgerottet, sind für Millionen von Fischtolefahrten. Vor allem haben sie jetzt Inside Out gemacht, wo nicht so viel Tief gehen konnte. Ja, genau, ja gut, die Schizophrenrate ist in die Höhe geschnitten. Sehr viele Kinder haben ihre Köpfe aufgeschnitten, um reinzugucken, um die Kommandozentrale, haben sich selber umgebracht. Aber spricht man dann von einem Nemo-Effekt mittlerweile oder so? Weil es sein, ja. Weil es fängt ja auch nach Werther von Johann Wolfgang von Goethe, die Leiden des jungen Werther, gab es ja auch so ein Massen-Selbstmord-Zeugs. Da haben sich sehr viele Menschen einfach umgebracht. Und dann gibt es den Papageno-Effekt, das ist der gegensätzliche Effekt, nämlich der wollte sich auch umbringen, aber dann hat er ja dann auch die Liebe gefunden und so und wurde dann durch gute Argumente vom Selbstmord abgehalten.
Die neue Staffel Game of Thrones, Alter!
Das ist so, das ist echt grossartig, es gibt halt zwei Effekte, also du musst echt aufpassen, wenn du Kunst machst oder einfach so ein crazy Typ bist wie Oberflug von Goethe, musst du echt aufpassen. Ja, also ich kenne den Werter-Effekt dann nur als fortgesetzt, dass man im Journalismus einfach nicht über Selbstmorde berichtet, weil einfach statistisch gesehen nach solchen Berichten einfach sich x Leute einfach töten. Ja, das ist der Wettereffekt. Ja klar, auch wenn man das natürlich nicht beabsichtigt, aber es ist einfach so. Aber es gibt aber auch, genau, im Gegensatz zum Papageno-Effekt, wenn du halt das gut aufarbeitest und sagst, es gab keine Gründe dafür usw., dann eben kann man sogar das Gegenteil auslösen. Das heißt, nicht darüber zu schreiben, ist auch die falsche Lösung. So viel zu Journalismus-Theorien. Ja, Journalismus ist nicht einfach. Egal, was man macht, man hat eine Verantwortung. Ja, das hat man bei vielen Berufen. Auch als Müllschredderer so eine Verantwortung. Schredder ich diesen Kühlschrank jetzt oder mache ich zunächst die Lange? Wenn du den Namen von Leuten auf einem Reiskorn im Ikea malst, da hast du eine relativ geringe Verantwortung. Ist dein Name auf irgendeinem Reiskorn? Ganz private Frage, mal kurz. Nein, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube schon, dass Florentin auf irgendeinem Reiskorn steht. Mag sein, vielleicht so als Herausforderung. Haha, langer Name. Neun Buchstaben. Bitch. Strand, den Gefährlein ist man auch heisser Sand. Nee, da gibt es diesen Stamm, ich glaube, auf der Insel North Sentinel oder so, die ist unter Indien irgendwo in dem Ozean. Und da lebt halt ein Stamm drauf, der einfach wie dieser Fluch der Karibik-Stamm aus Teil zwei, glaube ich, wo Jack Sparrow dann auch von dieser Insel gejagt wird. Diesen Stamm gibt es einfach, auf der Welt, das kann man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen, gibt es noch einen Stamm, der so weit weg von der Zivilisation ist, dass er einfach Leute umbringt. Und dann bei dem Tsunami 2004 hat man dann herausgefunden, wollte man dann gucken, ob die noch überlebt haben, weil man dachte, gut, wir wollen denen einfach helfen, das lebt offensichtlich lebender Menschen. Man weiß auch nicht genau, wie viele, zwischen 40 und 500, vermutet man, weil das sehr genaue Zahlen sind. Zwischen 78 und 7412.
Wie kommen die da rauf?
Und dann haben die versucht, den Kontakt aufzunehmen, um denen zu helfen.
Und dann hat man die Helikopter mit Pfeilen beschossen.
Das heißt, die haben überlebt, aus irgendeinem Grund, weiss man auch nicht wie, ist denn einfach eine Insel mitten da in der Gefahrenzone. Und da hat man die beschossen.
Und seit Jahren versuchen Leute, auch Wissenschaftler und Soziologen, versuchen mit denen Kontakt aufzunehmen, werden aber regelmäßig von denen beschossen, mit Pfeilen, Giftpfeilen oder normalen Speeren oder werden einfach gefangen genommen und dann gegessen. Das ist einfach so ein Kannibalenvolk, was da einfach lebt. Ich finde das so grossartig, dass in unserer weit vorgeschrittenen zivilisierten, technisierten Welt noch so ein Stamm lebt. Ja, vor allem, was zur Hölle müssen die denn denken, was da kommt, wenn da so ein Hubschrauber angeflogen kommt?
Die müssen denken, Alter, was ist denn jetzt los? Die müssen es ja, die haben wir da, die können das ja gar nicht verstehen. Also da werden dann irgendwelche Drachenmythen entstehen und der, der es geschafft hat, irgendwie mit dem Pfeil abzuschießen, ist der grosse Drachentöter oder was auch immer. Ich meine, die haben ja nicht in einem Ansatzweise eine Möglichkeit, das zu verstehen. Ja, vor allem, die werden ja auch Flugzeugstreifen oben sehen. Was denken die denn, was das ist? Wenn die oben so ein Flugzeug langfliegen sehen mit so einem riesen Kondensstreifen dahinter, denken die auch Chemtrails offensichtlich. Obwohl, ich habe auch mal von so einer Expedition gehört, wo auch so Forscher so einen Stamm aufgesucht haben. Und dann sind die angekommen und dann haben die die also freundlich begrüßt und dann haben die denen was zu gegeben und so. Und dann haben die auch für die so einen rituellen Tanz aufgeführt, zu ihren traditionellen Tanz, was sie da halt so machen und so. Und dann sind die Forscher wieder gegangen und haben das alles aufgeschrieben und sind gegangen. Und Jahre später kam dann nochmal eine Expedition da vorbei, die das Ganze sich nochmal näher angeschaut haben und die haben dann auch versucht, mit den Leuten zu reden, was da passiert ist und was die gesagt haben, was der Stamm erzählt hat, gesagt so, ja, nee, diesen Tanz und so, das existiert alles nicht, wir haben uns das kurzfristig ausgedacht, um das denen zu zeigen, weil wir davon ausgegangen sind, dass die sowas sehen wollen. So, das ist gar nicht deren eigentliche... Wir sprechen eigentlich auch ganz normales Hochdeut. Ja, genau, so dass die nur dachten, ja, okay, jetzt kommen die westlichen Leute und so, die wollen bestimmt, dass wir da irgendwie ums Feuer tanzen und unseren Ongo-Bongo-Tanz machen, also machen wir das mal, aber mit unserer eigenen Kultur hat das nicht viel zu tun.
Finde ich auch ganz geil irgendwie, dass die eigenen Erwartungen erfüllt werden. Eigentlich spielen wir hier immer Mario-Karten gegeneinander, machen die ganze Mario-Karten hier und machen Rundlauf den ganzen Tag.
Ja, zocken wir mal N64, so ein bisschen hinterher, klar, irgendwie, wir haben noch nicht die Sternenwelt freigeschaltet, aber an sich, wir haben eigentlich ein ganz geiles Leben.
Also manchmal werden dann Erwartungen auch dadurch erfüllt.
Aber das ist seltsam. Woher wissen die denn, was die Erwartungen von einer zivilisierten Welt sind an die Leute? Ich glaube, die waren schon ein bisschen besser angeboten, die hatten vielleicht schon mal hier und da Kontakt und so. Aber an sich finde ich es ein ganz interessanter Effekt zu sagen, dass du das für authentisch hältst, was die anderen denken, dass du sehen willst als authentisch, aber eigentlich gar nicht authentisch ist. Strange. Auch bei dieser Sentimental-Insel, da müsste ja manchmal auch, kommt ja bestimmt was angeschwommen auch am Strand.
Irgendwie so ein Wrack oder ein wirklich...
Sneaker einfach.
Ja, oder einfach wirklich schöner Turnschuh. Was machen die denn dann?
Was gehen die denn davon aus, was das ist, was so bunt, neongrün leuchtet und so Rollschuhe hintendran befestigt hat?
Ja, das stimmt schon. Finde ich schon echt mega interessant. Und es gibt halt nur Fotos von denen, wie die so Schattenmenschen wütend am Strand stehen, mit so Speeren in der Hand und in den Luft gestreckt. Also mega. Und die Leute dachten, ach nee, ich habe gerade die Augen zu dem Fotokollegen. Ich glaube, wenn da so ein Schuh angespült werden würde, werden da einfach erst mal 50 Pfeile reinfliegen in diese Schuhe. Das ist einfach der Art, wie die einfach mit allem Fremden umgehen, egal was passiert, einfach erst mal draufballern. Ich würde auch, glaube ich, ich würde die gerne erforschen, immer so verschiedene Dinge, die dann Strand spülen und gucken, wie die darauf reagieren und wie das auch die Welt verändert. Ich glaube, wenn man so einen Tamagotchi mal hinspülen würde. Oder irgendwann auch verarscht, einfach so eine Zielscheibe hinschicken und dann schießen da mit Bögen drauf. Also nicht einfach Spaß draus. Ihr werdet immer besser. Ja, so ein Furby und gucken, wie die reagieren. Ob das Gott aufnehmen oder als Furby beschießen. Ja, das ist doch nicht schlecht. Oder einfach mal so ein Fernseher hinstellen. Babyborn oder sowas. Ja. Oder Musik, auch denen einfach Musik vorspielen, einfach so irgendwie so Hardcore-Techno, wie die reagieren, einfach so. Ja, es gibt ja auch dann diese Versuche, die habe ich ja schon mal erzählt, mit diesem gelben U-Boot, was man hinter Haien hinterher schickt, diese Drohnen, die einfach dann so mega offensichtlich hinter dem Haien hinterher schwimmen die ganze Zeit, weil da so ein Peilsender drin ist. Warum macht man das nicht mit diesen modernen, humanoiden Robotern, die so, mittlerweile können ja durchs Gelände gehen und so, Urwald ist ja für die kein Problem, dass man einfach so einen Roboter hinstellt, dann ... Ja, Urwald ist ein riesiges Problem für die. Ja, was machen die denn dann, wenn der andere so ein Typ hinter den herläuft, und dann wie reagieren die denn auf den? Ich glaube, also Feile können die auch nicht kaputt machen, aber der ist doch nicht sauer, wenn er mit Feilen beschossen wird, weil das halt ein fucking Roboter, der wird einfach weiterhin einfach treu hinterhergehen, treu doof. Ja, so einer Drohne vielleicht eher, die man fliegen kann. Das ist echt krass. Es passt gar nicht mehr in die Welt. Da kann man doch einfach hingehen, oder? Also die Regierung warnt halt davor aus so ein paar Gründen, die man nicht ganz versteht. Zieh mir das eine Rüstung an oder so. Ich meine, wir haben, gegen Bögen können wir was machen, das ist kein Stress. Aber es gibt, werde ich noch so Urvölker, ich finde das total, ich fand das richtig faszinierend. Also danke noch mal an Faktastisch für diese tollen Einflüsse immer auf meiner Facebook-Timeline. Das sind sie in Arbeitstagversicht. Danke Faktastisch. Dankeschön. Danke. Ich muss sagen, wie fändest du die letzten Folgen? Ist ja selbstreferentiell, aber ich meine, heute ist immer hier Mädchenfreie Zone, ne? Jungs, Bruder, Männerabend, Weiber, ne? Kannst du auf Kommando röpsen? Nein. Nein, ich auch nicht. Nein. Also erstmal vielen Dank in die Community. Gute Arbeit. Wir hatten nämlich Angst, dass irgendwie von euch wieder so Scheisskommentare kommen, von wegen, die ist besser als die und die ist total scheisse und warum wollte sie die noch eingeladen und hier ist mein Top-Five-Ranking der Gäste und so. Cool, dass das nicht kam, dass sie das ganz gut aufgenommen hat, weil die auch nicht ständig im Podcast sind. Danke, obwohl Lena natürlich die Beste war, aber gut, eigentlich trotzdem. Ja, an sich war es mal ein Experiment, ein paar Gäste einzuladen. Ich glaube... Heute die neuere Rubrik. Die Top 3 Bildschirnhintergründe. Auf Platz 1. Weiss. Einfach weiss. Man sieht die Dinge gut abgegrenzt, man kann draufklicken, wo man will, man sieht den Cursor gut. Auf Platz 2. Die idyllische Graslandschaft, natürlich der Grasberg mit dem der blauen Himmel von Windows. Kennt jeder, es wirkt so ein bisschen wohnlich, wirkt gemütlich, niemand weiss genau, wo das ist. Ich finde es wirklich immer so ein bisschen unwirklich, so wie diese Teletubby-Welt, so diese Hügel, wo dann irgendwie der Horizont verschwindet unter diesen ganzen Hügeln. Ich fand diese Teletubby-Welt auch immer so ein bisschen gruselig, also gerade in der Ferne, also die war ja in der Nähe schon extrem verstörend, aber ich fand gerade die Ferne immer so beunruhigend, dass man nicht weiß, sind da nochmal andere Teletubbies oder kommt da nochmal eine Stadt irgendwann oder ist da einfach gar nichts mehr. Es ist so, als hätten so ADHS-Menschen sich eine Serie ausgedacht, weil da sind so viele Ideen drin, die null zusammenhängend sind.
Und das ist so, ich stimme vor, da war sind so viele Ideen drin, die null zusammenhängend sind.
Und das ist so, ich stimme vor, da war jemand im Raum, hat gesehen, okay, da ist ein Baby, da ist eine Sonne, alles klar, Baby in der Sonne, alles klar, dann sind ganz viele kleine Menschen, die haben Antennen auf dem Kopf und haben Bildschirme drauf und dann können die miteinander, der eine hat einen Roller, der andere hat einen Ball, der andere hat einen Zylinder auf die ganze Zeit, dann gibt's dann Staubsauger, alles klar, Staubsauger, dann gibt's dann Pudding, alles klar, die machen jeden Tag Pudding, Toast, Toast, One Toast, Tabby Toast, verdammt, da heisst das, Täter-Tabby's, warum bin ich da eher drauf gekommen, okay, alles ist grün, wie mein Bildschirm im Hintergrund. Und sie haben einen Staubsauger, der kann sprechen, der spricht und gibt ihnen immer Aufträge und das Baby schreit die ganze Zeit. Nunu, Nanu, Nanu, Nanu, Nanu, heisst Nunu. Und die Zuschauer schicken mir irgendwelche Sachen ein, die dann auf den Bäuchigen von den Sachen gezeigt werden. Alles klar, dann kommen verschiedene Kopfhörer hoch, so Lautsprecher, die die ganze Zeit wie so Propagandamaschinen aus dem Dritten Reich erklären, was zu tun ist gerade. Die T-Tap ist Hörnerflüch drauf. Einer heißt Dipsy. Dipsy, Lala, Bum-Bum, Popo und Kniepe. Alles klar. Kniepe ist schwarz. Zwei sind männlich, zwei sind weiblich, einer ist homosexuell. Puh, alles klar. Haben wir's doch, haben wir's, oder? Wir melden uns bei Ihnen. Aber genau so wirkt das einfach. Es ist wirklich ganz schön verstörend, diese Welt. Ja, aber es ist ja keine Welt so, das ist so, bei anderen Serien hat man so das Gefühl, man ist so in so einer Welt verankert irgendwie so. Du weisst, okay, was könnte da sein und man verlässt auch manchmal den Ort oder sowas, aber bei Tilt habe ich es nie. Du bist immer nur in deren Haus. Und da kommen auch irgendwie, woher kriegen die diesen Pudding so? Wer produziert den? Ist das so eine, also wo kommen die ganzen Geräte her? Hat das jemand den gebaut oder gegeben oder haben die das selber gebaut aus nichts, aus nur Gras? So das ist so ganz verstörend irgendwie, das ist wie so ein Experiment. Manchmal glaube ich auch genau, es sind vier Aliens, die mit ihrem Roller, ihrem Zylinder und dem Ball auf der Erde gelangert sind. Da hat man gedacht, okay, wir beobachten die jetzt. Ja, wir gucken mal, was passiert. Und dann hat man diese Kinderserie da rumgestrickt, um es möglichst offensichtlich zu vertuschen. Ach, du meinst auch, das war gar eine Serie, sondern eher ein Documentary sowas? Ja, es war eher, es fing an als Documentary und endete als Serie. Und da hat man denen halt immer diese Zeug gegeben, was man mal dem Raumschiff gefunden hat. Lala ist ja gestorben, Lala ist ja an Krebs verstorben, wurde dann durch einen Schauspieler ersetzt.
Und mittlerweile sind es nur noch vier Schauspieler.
Aber es waren halt, was man bei Wikipedia nachlesen kann, es war noch wirklich so eine Ballerina war in dem einen Kostüm.
Es waren wirklich einfach gute Tänzer, also wahnsinnig hochbezahlte Tänzer,
die so wirklich mit so einem
künstlerischen Ansatz da rangegangen sind,
haben die dann halt verkörpert.
Und es wurde von so ein paar Pädagogen geschrieben,
die halt versucht haben, möglichst viele Ideen
möglichst
kurz, billig reinzuproduzieren.
Sie haben
vier Jahre am Moskauer Staatsballett
getanzt und dann sehe ich hier drei Jahre lang, was ist das? Fernsehen, ich habe das Fernsehen da reingeschrieben. Sie waren die Gelbe, was meinten Sie damit? Asiatin wollte ich jetzt nicht. Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass Asiatin die Gelbe. Ja, ist Lala Asiatin eigentlich? Wie bei Power Rangers, wo auch die Gelbe einfach Asiatin ist. Und der Schwarze schwarz. Der Schwarze schwarz und der Indianer rot. Und der blaue andauernd besoffen ist. Hey, hey, das sind fünf High Fives. Der Rote ist Indianer, einfach so. Es ist wirklich ganz, ganz klassisch. Der Weisse ist der Super Power Ranger, der am stärksten ist, der alle immer rennen muss. Das ist so eine Blonde, ne? Ne, das ist ein Typ mit langen Haaren. Ein Dude. Ein Dude. Echt? Ja, der Weisse mit goldenen Teilen. Wer wärst du am liebsten? Rot. Immer rot. Gibt es dir so einen rosa Power Ranger? Pink Ranger, ja, das war das Mädchen. Natürlich. Ja. Natürlich. Muss das Mädchen wieder pink haben, kann auch als einzige nicht mit dem Technikkram umgehen, die da haben.. Darf ich hier das Auto fahren? Oh Gott, ey, es ist so dick. Macht immer die Sandwiches für die anderen Power Rangers. Es ist so durchschaubar und kriegt die ganzen Power Ranger Kinder. Ach, Power Ranger habe ich geliebt als Kind. Das ist der weirdste Scheiss, ich kann mich noch wirklich an Nachmittag erinnern, wo mein Freund und ich, wir einfach auf der Wiese waren, einfach nur Luft geboxt haben die ganze Zeit und gekämpft haben und wirklich wie in einem Anfall durch die Gegend gelaufen sind.
Ja.
Und uns vorgestellt haben, wir kämpfen gegen irgendwelche Monster und dann so, okay, wollen wir jetzt was Pudding essen und so und dann einfach, das war der Nachmittag, einfach vier und halb Stunden durch die Gegend boxen und dann isst du den Pudding und dann gehst du heim und so, das war's. Ich habe oft die Powerpuff Girls geguckt.
Ja, aber die kam ja später.
Man muss ganz, ich bin auch ein bisschen jünger, aber man muss echt. Ja, aber die kamen ja später.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen jünger, aber man muss echt dazu sagen, dass es wirklich, dann lief ja einfach nachmittag lang bei RTL 2, lief nur Powerpuff Girls oder Togo oder was das war, Super RTL. Aber es waren wirklich ewig lang und es ist einfach eine Serie, die einen bekloppt macht. Das andauert nur eine Schreierei, dann diese seltsamen Figürchen, eine seltsame Geschichte, alles nur mega schnell, alles in doppelter Geschwindigkeit abgespielt, glaube ich. Das macht einen, glaube ich, wahnsinnig als Kind. Ich war damals in Buttercup verliebt. Das war eine sehr anstrengende Romanze. Aber sie ist ganz nett. Professor X hat die dann, wie war da die Geschichte nochmal? Mit dem Trank. Der hat einen Trank gebraut. Ne, der kleine Kinder erschaffen, kleine Mädchen, er wollte sich ja drei kleine Mädchen erschaffen für sich. Und dann ist aus Versehen irgendwie die X-Flasche mit reingefallen, immer diese Sachen, die dann immer reinfallen und direkt neben dem grossen Topf stehen, wo man die Kinder gerade baut. Und dann haben die Superkräfte bekommen. Ja, und fliegen dann durch die Gegend. Und wurden dann noch von einem radio-tiefen Elch gebissen, aber das sieht man... Das ist erst in der Staffel zwei relevant. Genau, es kam das dann. Da kam dann diese ganze Elch-Storyline. Oh Gott, hat die mich genervt. Und dann ist es, wenn das plötzlich Spider-Man ab Staffel drei eine Majorrolle spielt. Ja, dann hatten die alle Elchkräfte und so und konnten dann irgendwie so Brunftschrei machen. Was passiert, wenn eigentlich ein Spider-Man dich beißt? Aber das ist eine gute Frage. Dann habe ich nicht Spider-Man-Man. Ja, genau, aber du bist halt, also du hast nicht die Superkräften von Spinnen nur, sondern du bist halt so eine Mischung aus Mensch und Spider-Man. Also Mensch und Mensch und du bist so ein... Ja, so ein Drittel, ein Viertel Spinnen. Also nicht ganz so gut mehr. Also eine Schwäche ihrer Spider-Man wahrscheinlich wäre einfach die Antwort. Aber eigentlich müsste doch Spider-Man mittlerweile schon mit jedem Kontakt gehabt haben, oder? Also wenn man mal alle Stammbäume zurückrechnet, hat, glaube ich, ist jeder mit Spider-Man irgendwo verwandt. So wie mit Genghis Khan, der irgendwie mit jedem irgendwie verwandt ist. Ich glaube, ich kann man auch Spider-Man auf alle zurückfinden. Wer glaubst du ist eher mit Genghis Khan verwandt von uns beiden? Wer hat mehr von Genghis Khan? Wer ist ein bisschen flinker, wer weiss genau, wie die Feinde gerade zu uns stehen, wer weiss genau, wie er die Schachfiguren auf dem Schlagfeld des Lebens positionieren muss, um den nächsten Schritt zu gehen? Wer glaubst du es eher der Jäger von uns?
Du.
Danke.
Lass dich mal drücken.
Dinge, die Genghis Khan gesagt hat. Komm mal her, komm mal her. Lass dich mal drücken. Komm mal her. Ja, Jingles Khan. Was ist deine Lieblingsgeschichtliche Figur, die ordentlich für Furore gesorgt hat? Was ist meine Lieblingsgeschichtliche Figur? Das ist eine sehr interessante Frage. Also historische Figuren, die die Crazy Stuff gemacht haben. Goleo, würde ich sagen. Ich finde, der hat schon richtig gute Arbeit geleistet damals. Der war cool, ne? Top, ja. Ich war letztens in einem Restaurant, wo es einen Mahatma-Gandhi-Burger gab. Das fand ich auch sehr lustig, einfach einen Burger zu benennen nach jemandem, der primär dafür bekannt ist, dass er Hungerstreiks begangen hat. Da hatte ich auch mal eine Idee nach einem Tweet. Kennt ihr das Gefühl, wenn man die Mikrowelle bei genau null Minuten, null Sekunden aufmacht? Ja, wie eine Bombenentschärfung oder sowas, ne? Nee, und dann hätte ich gesagt, so ein Gefühl, so ein Gefühl der Erlösung hatte Gandhi auch, nachdem er, weiss ich nicht, ein Volk vor dem Tod befreit hat oder so. Quasi jetzt mal diese Lappalie, wo man, wie ich mich wirklich sehr darüber freue, gleichzeitig mit einer Tat. Ist halt so ein klassisches Twitter-Format-Ding, was mich dann auch ein bisschen ärgert, aber vielleicht liegt da was. Schreibt einfach eine Postkarte. Ich finde, wenn dich dein eigener Tweet nicht ein bisschen ärgert, ist ist er auch nicht gut. Das hat er auf Twitter auch nichts zu suchen. Auf Twitter müssen immer Sachen sein, die zu 20 Prozent aus Selbsthass geschrieben wurden. Was auch wieder so ein Tweet wäre. Man kommt aus dieser Spirale. Man kommt aus dieser Spirale. Twitter-Kralle nicht raus. Was gibt es sonst in unserem Leben? Was haben wir erlebt? Wir haben mit sehr vielen Frauen gesprochen. Was macht das jetzt mit uns? Wie geht's dir danach? Also ich hab mir gedacht, muss ich erstmal wieder erstmal eine Runde ordentlich, was machen Männer, ich weiß nicht genau. Bier trinken. Ich musste ordentlich erst mal ein Bier geäxt und dann noch ein bisschen Tischkicker gespielt und dann ordentlich ein Wett-Hotdog-Essen machen und dann, ja, dann ging es mir wieder gut.
Ja, nee, war interessant, war eine gute. Hey Leute, passt mal auf! Falls ihr denkt, oh, das war nicht so geil. Ich glaube, dass man, also wenn ich mir einen Podcast vorstelle, den man gerade hört beim Schlafen oder so, beim Einschlafen, wenn dann jemand sagt, hey Leute, pass mal auf, ist Abschalter sofort.
Ich glaube, das ist der Let's-List-Moment, wo man dann anfängt zuzuhören.
Ja, wenn ihr am Freitag Moin Moin schaut, da sind wir da.
Gut, macht's gut, ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche, hauen rein, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wir sagen Tschüss, das war Stefan und wir heben ab in drei, das war Florentin und ich wünsche euch auch ein bisschen.
Ciao. Stefan und wir heben ab in drei, das auf Lohen Team und ich bitte euch auch ein bisschen.
Ciao.